AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
TODAY'S HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
PLANT REVENUE AND TAXATION WE
ARE STILL REQUIRING THAT MASS
BE WARM WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM ARE ON THE IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SAY IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE AMOUNTS WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I'LL
ASK YOU TO POACH THE MICROPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I
WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. WE WILL
ALSO BE. USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN.
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
PLAN TO DO SO AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AS WE HAVE ONLY A
LIMITED NUMBER OF BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MEETING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE. YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2098 AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO HELP
BILL. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. NOW I'D
LIKE TO GO A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR THE BILLS
BEING TAKEN UP TODAY WE WON'T
TAKE NO MORE THAN TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OR WITH CONCERNS. BUSINESSES
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY. ALL
SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND OUR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY. WE HAVE THREE
BILLS ON OUR PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR THESE BILLS ARE FILE
ITEM FIVE SB SIX SIX SEVEN
SENATOR ROTH. FILE ITEM EIGHT
SB EIGHT TWENTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNOR MENTAL
ORGANIZATION AND FILE ITEM NINE
SB EIGHT TWENTY FIVE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENT
FINANCES. FINALLY IN FILE ITEM
ONE AB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA HAS
BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S
HEARING. WELL IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE A QUORUM. IS HIGHLY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL BEFORE WE LOSE IT.
BURKE WHEN. GREAT GRAYSON.
LIVING HERE MAYES MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS. BURKE YEAH RIVAS
SARATOGA. WE HAVE A QUORUM. I
HAVE BEEN AND THAT WAS THAT. WE
NEED. FOR THE- I AM FOLLOWING
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WITH
TIMELY COLORADO CONSENT
CALENDAR. THANK IF WE HAD TO
GET. OKAY IT DOES NOT. BURKE
FINE BURKE A FIVE WIN. WHEN I
AGREE GRAYSON. GRAYSON I LEVINE.
LEVINE I MAYES MAYES I MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
ARTWORK HI BURKE I RIVAS SERICA.
THE CONSENT CALENDARS PASS. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS A PASSED IN.
ALL. OKAY SO NOW WE'RE CALLING
HOPEFULLY SENATORS HERTZBERG
ALLEN. THE CHILDREN GLAZER
FEEDS.
RIGHT YEAH. SENATOR YOU
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN ON FILE ITEM
SEVEN SB SEVEN NINETY TWO WHEN
YOU ARE READY. I DON'T KNOW I
JUST I MEAN LIKE I. THINK. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT WERE SET. OKAY
GOOD AFTERNOON- THAT ENSURING
MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
DILIGENT WORK ON THIS BILL. AND
I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. SB SEVEN NINETY TWO
WOULD REQUIRE RETAILERS WITH
ONLINE SALES TOTALING MORE THAN
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
TO REPORT THE AMOUNT OF TAXABLE
SALES THEY COME PLEADING EACH
CITY OR COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL IS A TRANSPARENCY
MEASURE. DESIGNED TO SHED LIGHT
ON THE MANIPULATION OF THE
BRADLEY BURNS UNIFORMS LOCAL
SALES TAX LAW. BY MAJOR
CORPORATIONS AND A HANDFUL OF
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE. UNDER
BRADLEY BYRNE SALES TAX REVENUE
IS ALLOCATED TO THE POINT. OF
SALE. FOR BRICK AND MORTAR
STORES THIS MEANS ALLOCATING
THE REVENUE TO THE JURISDICTION
THE STORE IS LOCATED AT. ONLINE
RETAILERS HOWEVER ARE ALLOWED
TO CHOOSE WHERE THEY ALLOCATE
SALES TAX REVENUES THIS ALLOWS
CORPORATIONS TO DIRECT REVENUES
TO A SINGLE JURISDICTION IN THE
STATE ANYWHERE THEY HAVE A
WAREHOUSE DISTRIBUTION CENTER.
OR EVEN A SALES OFFICE.
CORPORATIONS USE THIS AS
LEVERAGE TO EXTRACT DEALS FROM
CITIES ALLOWING THE COMPANIES
TO OBTAIN A SHARE OF THE SALES
TAXES THAT THEY COLLECT. BOB IN
CITIES WILL GIVE THESE
CORPORATIONS BETWEEN 50% AND
85% OF THE SALES TAX REVENUE.
ALLOCATED TO THEIR JURISDICTION.
TAXES THAT WERE PAID BY
RESIDENTS FROM OTHER CITIES
AROUND THE STATE. AT A TIME
WHEN ONLINE SHOPPING IS AT ITS
PEAK. AND CITIES ARE STRUGGLING
TO FIND PUBLIC PROGRAMS DUE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
COMPANIES ARE SIPHONING
BILLIONS IN TAXPAYER DOLLARS
THROUGH THESE AGREEMENTS.
MEMBERS A FEW CITIES THAT
BENEFIT FROM THESE DEALS HAVE
SUBMITTED LETTERS OF OPPOSITION.
ONE OF THEM IS THE CITY OF
CUPERTINO. I THOUGHT IT MIGHT
BE HELPFUL TO TALK ABOUT WHY
THAT CITY OPPOSES THIS BILL. AS
YOU KNOW CUPERTINO ONE OF THE
WEALTHIEST CITIES IN THE STATE
IS HOME TO APPLE. ONE OF THE
WEALTHIEST COMPANIES IN THE
WORLD. AND CUPERTINO HAS A
SPECIAL DEAL WITH APPLE. EVERY
TIME ANYONE IN CALIFORNIA BY
SAY A PHONE OR AN IPAD OR A
COMPUTER FROM APPLE ONLINE.
APPLE SENDS ALL THE LOCAL
PORTION OF THAT SALES TAX THEY
COLLECT THE CUPERTINO. IN
RETURN CUPERTINO GETS 35% OF
THAT SALES TAX REVENUE TO
APPLE. 35% THANKS TO THIS DEAL.
AND THE SURGE IN ONLINE
SHOPPING LAST YEAR. THE CITY
GAVE APPLE MORE THAN FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN JUST TWO
QUARTERS OF THE LAST YEAR. THAT
WAS MONEY PAID BY YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. AT NIGHT OF IT
WENT TO THE CITIES IN WHICH
THEY LIVE. APPLE IN CUPERTINO
WE'RE NOT ALONE. MANY ITIES
AROUND THE STATE HAVE SIMILAR
DEALS. WITH BEST BUY HOME DEPOT
AND- MANY OTHER COMPANIES. NOW
THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE YOU IS
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA'S DESERVE TO KNOW
JUST HOW MUCH REVENUE THESE
TYPES OF AGREEMENTS ARE
SIPHONING FROM EACH OF OUR
CITIES. BUT UNDER TODAY'S
SYSTEM THERE IS NO WAY FOR ANY
OF US TO NOW. SB SEVEN NINETY
TWO WOULD PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IS NICK ROMO FROM THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND STATES
STACY HEATON FROM RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE CONNECT US
WITH NICK ROMAN OF THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES FIRST PLEASE. YOU CAN
HAVE A BETTER WRITER I'M SORRY.
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU- CARE MEMORY NECRO ON
BEHALF OF THE OF CALIFORNIA
CITY CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
SEVEN NINETY TWO TODAY ABOUT
THE ANALYSIS MENTIONED- THIS IS
A MEASURE THAT AIMS TO BETTER
INFORM THE PUBLIC OUR STATE OR
COUNTY OF THE IMPACT OF THE
FLOW OF GOODS IN ONLINE
TRANSACTIONS. WE ARE AWARE THAT
WE HAVE CITIES ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS ISSUE AS IT STADS TODAY
BUT THE AUTHOR RIGHTFULLY
POINTS OUT I WILL LEGISLATING
RATHER IN THE DARK WE NEED MORE
INFORMATION THIS TO OPT OUT PUT
OUT A FINE A POINT ON THAT
TODAY I'M OUR BEST SALES TAX-
ANALYSTS ARE CONSULTANTS-
MARKETING STAFF ONLY WORKING
WITH ABOUT HALF OF THE DATA.
FROM SALES TAX ALLOCATION
ACROSS THE STATE WE'RE ONLY
ABLE TO MODEL- THE IMPACT OF
ONLINE TRANSACTIONS AND BADLY
BYRNE'S MOVE MAY WELL WE'LL GET
HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S POINT
EIGHTY TWO CITY THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE MORE DATA WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
ONLINE SALES ARE. THEY AND WHY
YOU WANT TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE BENEFIT I FELT A GROUP OF
CITY MANAGER SOUNDS CALCULATOR
CALIFORNIA CITY GOT STANDING
FOR AN EIGHTY TWO THIRTY IN THE
STATE THEY CAME TOGETHER IN THE
FALL TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT DO WE NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS DISCUSSION
FAILED GREETING AND- MORE DATA
IS NEEDED ON A DAY THAT I
CALLED ONE SEVEN NINETY TWO. I
WILL ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
TODAY THAT WE ARE CONCERNED THE
LEAGUE CALIFORNIA CITY ABOUT
DISADVANTAGED MEANS THE IMPACT
OF DISTRIBUTION SENATE IMPACT
ONLINE SALES ON THE CITY TO
HOST THE DISTRIBUTION NETWORK
WE CAN FIND SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
EQUITABLE TAMPINES LESIONS THAT
CAN MOVE THE HEAD OF PACKED
INTO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
TAKING IT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT HOW
DO WE SUPPORT THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE HOW THE DISTRIBUTION
NETWORK AS WELL AS- OKAY MORE
EQUITABLE ALLOCATION OF SALES
TAXES ACROSS ACROSS THE STATE.
SO THAT WILL BE SUPPORT SB.
SEVEN NINETY TWO THANK AND
APPRECIATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE MODERN NOW COULD US WITH.
HIDDEN OF THE CAN REP. OF GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
STAY HEAT THOROUGH COUNTY WHERE.
OF ARE PEOPLE THIRTY FIVE WORLD
STATEWIDE. I'M SPEAKS TODAY IN
FAVOR OF THE SENATE BILL SEVEN
NINETY TWO AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BENEFIT FROM THE
DISTRIBUTION OF SALES TAX UNDER
BRADLEY BYRNE. I TIED TO THE
JURISDICTION OF THE PRECURSORS
RESIDENTS ARE NOW FINDING
DIMINISHING REVENUES AS YOU
BRADLEY BURNS ALLOCATIONS ARE
MADE AT THE POINT OF SALE OR
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS COMPANY
OPPOSITE THEIR WAREHOUSES ARE
LOCATED. BROKING ENTITIES ARE
NOT NATURAL STAE FOR
CENTRALIZED DISTRIBUTION OR
SALES OF GOODS FROM MAJOR
RETAILERS AND THAT MAKES IT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO COMPETE OR
INCENTIVIZE COMPANIES TO LOCATE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. THE CURRENT
PRACTICE OF THE KICKBACK
AGREEMENTS WERE MEANING THAT
THE POLICIES TO RETAILERS A
PERCENTAGE OF BRADLEY BURNS
ALLOCATIONS IN EXCHANGE FOR.
CERTAIN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
BENEFITS ALSO SKEWED TOWARD
URBAN AND SUBURBAN AREAS WITH
MORE SPACE FOR INDUSTRIAL
DEVELOPMENT AND AWAY FROM OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES. SO THIS COOK
ARE ARE RURAL AREAS IN A VERY
DISADVANTAGED- POSITION WITH
REGARD TO THE SHIFT. TO ONLINE
SALES PARTICULARLY SINCE MANY
OF OUR WORLD I RESIDENTS NOW DO
A LOT MORE ONLINE PURCHASING.
WE FEEL LIKE THIS BILL IS A
GREAT START TO JUST GATHER DATA
ON HOW IT'S IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR COUNTIES.
AND TO SEE EXACTLY HOW THESE
AGREEMENTS ARE IMPACTING. SALES
TAX DISTRIBUTION AND WE URGE
YOUR AYE. VOTE ON THE MEASURE
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH
THE WATER MODERATOR PLEASE NOW
OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TESTIMONY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN PLEASE TO ONE
OF THEM VERO. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
AND IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY SUPPORT VIA REMOTE
VIDEO AT THIS TIME. SEEING
NONE. AND IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
MODERATE WOULD YOU PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH AND HUMAN ANY
FOR THE CITY OF FRESNO. HI YES.
RIGHT HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- ENGINE THAT
HERE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO SB
SEVEN NINETY TWO- I UNDERSTAND-
WHAT THE INTENT OF- I
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS IN PRINT
WITH THE BILL AND THIS IS VERY
MUCH A DATA COLLECTION
INFORMATION GATHERING BILL
HOWEVER THE CITY REMAINS-
OPPOSED TO THE ULTIMATE INTENT
WHICH REALLY GET THAT THE
TIGHTEST ALLOCATION ISSUE AN
ISSUE WHICH WE FEEL IS
DISPENSED WITH- YOU YEARS AGO
WHEN THE GOVERNOR HAD VETOED SB
FIVE THIRTY WINES- WHICH WOULD
SHIFT WE- POINT OF SALE FROM MY
FROM DEPLETED DISTRIBUTION TO
THE PLACE OF A DELIVERY- THREE
THOSE OF YOU WHO AREN'T
FAMILIAR WITH THE SALES TAX
SHARING AGREEMENT I KNOW FIVE
NOW HAS. ON SEVERAL IN PLACE
AND FOR A COMMUNITY LIKE FRESNO
THAT'S BEEN PREDOMINATELY- ADS
FOCUSED- VERY MUCH- YOU KNOW
MOST OF OUR JOBS AND OUR
ECONOMY- WHAT IS FOR MANY MANY
YEARS- DEPENDING ON THE AG
INDUSTRY HAS NOW BECAUSE OF THE
SALES TAX SHARING AGREEMENTS
AND- YOU KNOW ATTRACTING
RETAILERS TO COMMENT. YOU KNOW
HOST AT. AND HAVE OUR CITY-
THERE GET YOUR- HAS NOW BEEN A
TO- YOU KNOW CHANGE OR ACT.
SITUATION DRAMATICALLY- YOU
KNOW WHEN THE GOVERNOR HAD MADE
HIS DECISION ON THIS ISSUE AND-
APPROVED EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE BY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA. TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
MORE TRANSPARENCY WITH THESE
AGREEMENTS- YEAH HE HAD
MENTIONED IN HIS I SIGNATURE
AND HIS DOES. I THINK YOU GET A
MESSAGE ACTUALLY- BUT THIS WAS
AN IMPORTANT LOCAL TOOL THAT
HELPS TO- YOU KNOW HOW. THAT
ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC ACTIVITY-
SPECIFICALLY IN RURAL AREAS-
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT UNTIL
WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE A MUCH
BROADER DISCUSSION OVER WHAT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TOOLS ARE
AVAILABLE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THIS YEAR ONE THAT- IS
CERTAINLY VERY VALUABLE I MEAN
FOR OUR CITY INTO FOR THESE
REASONS- WE CONTINUE TO REMAIN
ON. OPPOSED TO THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU WITH THE MODERN NOW
CONNECTED MACHINE. I'M IN A
ROOM IN YOUR NAME THE CITY OF.
R. S. YEAH- THANK YOU BYE HERE
IN MEMBERS MACHEL PROVIDED BY
LAW WITH NO CONNECTION ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF PARIS-
VERY- SIMILAR TO SIGNIFY THE
FINISHED AND WE REMAIN OPPOSED
TO AT THE SEVEN NINETY TWO IN
CENTER GLAZERS REPEATED
ATTEMPTS TO ATTACK E. COMMERCE
AND- PARIS IS A- CITY. IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE WHICH PRIOR TO
THE CREATIONOF SOME OF THESE
HE- COMMERCE AGREEMENT LIVED IN
GENERATIONAL POVERTY WE HAVE
SEVENTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS WHO
LIVE IN PARIS MOST OF THEM
PREDOMINANTLY LATINO AND BLACK.
AND PRIOR TO SOME OF THE E.
COMMERCE AGREEMENT. THERE WAS
JUST NO WORK TO WORK WITHIN THE
CITY OF PARIS- WE ARE ALSO
HAMPERED BY WE HAVE- AT. AN
AIRFORCE BASE IN STILL A HUGE
SWAP WITH CITY CANNOT BE
DEVELOPED DUE TO REGULATIONS-
BOUNDARIES THESE TAX SHARING
AGREEMENT. HOW BEEN THE
LIFEBLOOD FOR THE FIFTIETH CARE
THEY OUT. BUILD NEW- PARK IN
GREEN AREAS THEY'VE ALLOWED US
TO PROVIDE MORE SERVICES TO OUR
RESIDENTS OUR CITY OP. IF YOU
COULD BUT YOU KNOW IF WE TRIED
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE- AGREEMENT AND WE DON'T
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THOSE
PEOPLE BUT AS GOVERNOR NEWSOM
SAID. ON THIS TOPIC. FOR OUR
CITIES WHO DO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES AND HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE THIS HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE ONLY. ECONOMIC TOOL
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO AVAIL
OURSELVES UP I THINK IT THERE
SHOULD BE A CONVERSATION. ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY BUT ALSO. WE
SHOULD RECORD THAT AB FORTY
FIVE ONE FORTY INTO LAW BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM WHICH DEALS
WITH THE AGREEMENT AND IS THE
SOLE PURPOSE OF PROVIDING
TRANSPARENCY PROCEED
CALIFORNIA. I THINK THE BILL IS
A ONE SIZE FITS ALL AND I DON'T
THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE PUBLIC
POLICY BUT IT'S A CALIFORNIA
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WILL
REMAIN OPPOSED. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
MODERATOR WE OPEN THE MAIN LINE
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL- OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. CERTAINLY AGAIN IF
THERE'S ANY TESTIMONY PLEASE
PRESS. ONE NOW THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN. ZERO AT THIS TIME THERE
IS NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION VIA REMOTE VIDEO
STATION AT THIS TIME. SEEING
NONE. HI IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. DR KIRK. FIRST ALL
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND- AS YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD I'D VERY MUCH LIKE TO BE
A CO AUTHOR ON THE BILL. SECOND
YOU KNOW. IF TO TRY AND FAVOR
ONE CITY OVER ANOTHER PARRIS
HAS ITS PROBLEMS FRESNO HAS ITS
PROBLEMS THERE ARE SIMILAR
CITIES WITH SIMILAR PROBLEMS IN
PARIS AND FRANCE NEVER TAKING
MONEY AWAY FROM THEM END. I
MEAN A TAX BREAK TO. THE
RICHEST CORPORATIONS IN THE
WORLD. THIS IS. THIS THIS IS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
THEIR TAX DOLLARS SUPPORTING
APPLE THE RICHEST THE RICHEST.
OF RICH. CORPORATIONS AND
AMAZON RIGHT UP THERE WITH THEM
WHY ARE WE SUBSIDIZING THESE
COMPANIES. AT THE PRICE OF
TAKING AWAY MONEY FROM TOWNS
THAT ARE JUST AS DESERVING AS
FRESNO AND PARIS THIS IS GOTTA
STOP. I AM ASHAMED OF OUR
GOVERNOR FOR VETOING THAT BILL
THAT I HELPED GET PASSED AND I
HOPE THAT WE CAN OPEN PEOPLE'S
EYES WITH THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
IN THE GAME MR GRAIN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR CENTER NICE TO SEE-
I THINK YOU'RE AWARE LIVE VOTED
AGAINST THE PREVIOUS VERSIONS
NO I ACTUALLY- NOT SURE BY THE
VIEWPOINT OF MY COLLEAGUE WHO
JUST SPOKE IN THAT I THINK THE
GOVERNOR. HAD GOOD REASON TO BE
TOLD BELT. TO BE SIMPLE BUT I
CAN SEE FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
REPRESENT YOUR CONSTITUENCY WHY
THIS IS ADVANTAGEOUS. TO THAT
COMMUNITY I SEE IT IS- YOU KNOW
DETRIMENTAL NOT ADVANTAGEOUS TO
MY COMMUNITY. I WANT TO GIVE
YOU AN OPPORTUNITY THOUGH TO-
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH THAT
STATEMENT TO TELL ME KIND OF
HOW. HOW YOU DISAGREE AND HOW
THIS IS IN THE INTEREST OF MY
COMMITTEES TOO OFTEN- AND
YOU'VE HEARD ME TALK ABOUT THIS
BEFORE THAT GOT THE HOUSE THE
HAVE NOTS OF CALIFORNIAN HOW I
FEEL. OUR COASTAL AND URBAN
NEIGHBORS TREAT US IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA- WHICH IS OFTEN-
EXPECTING US JUST TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR THE SCRAPS FROM THEIR
TABLES AND- AND PUTTING
MEASURES IN PLACE THAT FRANKLY.
BECAUSE OUR CONSTITUENTS TO
DRIVE SEVERAL HOURS A DAY FOR
JOBS- YOU KNOW IMPACTING OUR
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK AND-
THEN CONVERSELY NOT BUILDING
MORE LANES BECAUSE WE'RE SAVING
THE WORLD FROM CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THEREFORE CAN'T MAKE. LIFE
EASIER ON THOSE VERY FAMILY
SAYS A LOT OF HYPOCRISY IS THAT
I SEE- I KNOW THAT'S NOT WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM- YOU KNOW
I'VE WORKED TOGETHER ON MANY
MANY ISSUES SO. JUST HELP ME
UNDERSTAND HOW YOUR PERSPECTIVE
AS TO WHERE THIS IS
ADVANTAGEOUS FOR MY COMMUNITY.
THREE THE CHAIR ABSOLUTELY.
THAT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AND APPROPRIATE ALWAYS YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS AND IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS. YOU KNOW THE
BILL THAT WE HAD THE DEBATE
ABOUT BEFORE WAS A BILL THAT
SAID. NO NEW DEALS. THE WORK ON
A ROLL BACK ANY OF THE EXISTING
DEALS THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN.
MADE WITH. YOUR CITIES JUST
SAID THAT GOING FORWARD THERE
SHOULD BE ANY MORE KICKBACK
AGREEMENTS WHILE WE EVALUATE.
THE STATE OF OUR TAX SYSTEM.
THIS BILL ALL IT SAYS IS. BUT
REPORT THAT DATA TO THE TAX
AUTHORITY SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
IT ANOTHER DEBATE ABOUT THE
FACTS- YOU MAY ARGUE OR SOMEONE
MAY ARGUE THAT THIS DISTRICT
THAT HURTS MY CITY OR HELPS
YOURS. BUT NOBODY HAS ACTUALLY
THE FAX ON WHO'S GAINING AND
WHO'S LOSING. UNDER THE
EXISTING TAX SYSTEM THAT WE
ADDRESSING THIS BILL SO I WOULD
SAY DEAL WITH RESPECT. EVEN
THOUGH YOU MAY FEEL IT MIGHT
DISADVANTAGE YOUR CITIES YOU
COULD BE VERY SURPRISED- WHEN
THE FAX CAME OUT IF THIS BILL
IS ENACTED TO ACTUALLY SEE WHO
WHO DOES GAIN. AND WHO DOES
NOT. AND I CERTAINLY ALIGN
MYSELF. WITH THE COMMENTS FROM
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER. WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS MAY BENEFIT FRESNO
BUT GO DOWN THE FREEWAY A FEW
MILES AND THAT NEXT
IMPOVERISHED TOWN MAYBE THE ONE
THAT'S REALLY BEING HEARD. SO I
SUPPORT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES AND OTHERS.
LET'S MAKE SURE WE'RE- MAKING
THOSE DECISIONS FOR THE RIGHT
REASONS AND WE CAN SEE THE
WHOLE PLAYING FIELD. THAT OUR
TAX POLICY AFFECTS AND THAT'S
ALL THIS BILL WILL DO AND
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
SENATOR ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER MASON. EVEN THOUGH I'VE
GOT A GREAT AFFECTION FOR OF
THE DAY THAT THE GENTLEMAN IN
FRONT OF ME- WHO REPRESENTS A
PART OF THE STATE THAT IS-
UNDER SERVED AND- AND
DISADVANTAGED I ALSO REPRESENT
A PART OF THE STATE THAT IS
UNDERSERVED ANDDISADVANTAGED
IN FACT THE CITY OF PARIS
ALTHOUGH I DON'T REPRESENT THE
CITY OF PARIS CITY PERSON VERY
CLOSE. TO MY DISTRICT AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN IN
INLAND CALIFORNIA THAT FEEL
THAT THEY THEY NEED TO COME UP
HAVE HAVE SOME SORT OF A LEG UP
THE PROBLEM REALLY IS IN
CALIFORNIA R. I. TAX SYSTEM AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL IS COMPLETELY
SCREWED UP IT HAS BEEN FOR A
VERY VERY LONG TIME AND THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE. ARE ALSO
A DISADVANTAGED- ARE ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TRY TO. GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
REVENUE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
JUST THE BASICS. OF SERVICE SO
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT THE SAME TIME WE NEED TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND- WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH IS JUST TO YOUR
POINT- YOU'RE YOU'RE EXACTLY
RIGHT WHEN YOU HAVE ONE
COMMUNITY DOING IT AT THE NEXT
MEETING WHAT TO DO WITH THE
NEXT THING WE WANT TO DO IT.
YOU'VE GOT A SYSTEM THAT IS
COMPLETELY SCREWED UP I THINK.
OF THE- THE STRATEGY THAT
YOU'VE GOT HERE MAKES AN AWFUL
LOT OF SENSE WHICH IS WHY
SECONDED. THE MOTION AND I'LL
BE SUPPORTING TODAY THANK YOU
FOR. OF YOUR DILIGENT WORK IN
THIS REGARD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR I'M- I THINK DIFFERENT
CONCERNS THAN- THOSE RAISED BY
FIVE EIGHT THAT THE FOLKS WHO
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION-
ANOTHER IN OPPOSITION LETTER
POINTED OUT THAT THIS CREATES A
DUPLICATIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT ACTUALLY
WE ALREADY HAVE THE DATA
NECESSARY TO DO THIS ANALYSIS
AND TO HAVE THIS KIND OF
INSIGHT AND TRANSPARENCY CAN
YOU JUST. SPEAK TO THAT.
CONCERNED YEAH I MEAN WE'VE
WE'VE TRIED FOR YEARS TO TRY TO
GET THE ACTUAL FACTS. AND THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES- IN THEIR OWN
WAY AS TRIED AS WELL AND NONE
OF US CAN GET THE- THE DATA ON
IT THESE TYPES OF ONLINE-
PURCHASES. AND WHERE THOSE TAX
MONIES ARE GOING SO WE HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO AND THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL FOCUSES ON DATA
COLLECTION. IT IS INFORMATION
THAT RETAILERS ALREADY PROVIDE.
TERMS OF WHERE SOMEONE IS
ORDERED THE PRODUCT FROM SO
IT'S NOT THAT DIFFICULT. FOR
THEM TO- ACCUMULATE THAT THAT
INFORMATION AND SHARE WITH ALL
OF US IN A TRANSPARENT WAY
THAT'S ALL THIS BILL REALLY
TRIES TO DO AT THIS POINT AND
THEN WE CAN HAVE OUR SPIRITED
DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER THE TAX
LAW SHOULD BE CHANGED OR NOT.
AT LEAST LET'S GET THAT
INFORMATION NO IT'S NOT
AVAILABLE TODAY. ALL RIGHT
THANKS FOR CLARIFYING NOT ANTI
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR FOCUS ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL THEY THINK MUCH. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NINE
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING
THE MOMENT SUGGESTING SUGGESTED
ANY MOUSE ANALYSIS TO INCREASE
THRESHOLD FOR QUALIFIED
RETAILERS TO FIFTY MILLION IN
QUALIFIED SALES WITH THAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
OR WORK IN THIS AREA WITH ME AS
WELL THIS IS A DATA COLLECTION
BILL. OTHERS MAY WANT TO MAKE A
BIGGER DEAL ABOUT IT BECAUSE
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE NEXT
DEBATE TO FOLLOW WHETHER OUR
TAX CODE IS FAIR IT TREATS ALL
OF OUR CITIES FAIRLY AND THAT'S
THAT'S GOING TO BE A SPIRITED
ONE BUT LET'S AT LEAST DO IT
WHERE WE HAVE THE FACTS ON THE
TABLE FOR ALL OF US TO SEE. WHO
THE WINNERS WHO ARE THE LOSERS
WE KNOW RIGHT NOW THE BIGGEST
CORPORATIONS IN THE WORLD OF
THE WINNERS THEY'RE GETTING
MORE THAN BILLION A BILLION AND
WITH ONLINE SALES ROCKETING
MAYBE MULTIPLE BILLIONS IN
THESE KICKBACKS FROM SOME
CITIES BUT LET'S SO LET'S GET
THE FACTS SO WE CAN NOW HAVE
THAT NEXT LEVEL I HOPE OF
DEBATE. ABOUT OUR TAX POLICY IN
THE STATE BUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU MISS
HAVING TO CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE. HI BURKE
AYE WIN. WINDOW GRAY. GRAYSON
GRAYSON I. LIVING LEVINE I.
MAYES MAYES AYE MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS. HM OR SI QUIRK
GROUP I RIVAS RIVAS ICY AREN'T
SO. BILL PASSES SEVEN ZERO
THAT'S BECAUSE I WAS SEVENTY I
THINK YOU. RIGHT WHERE
APPARENTLY THE SENATORS WERE
CHECKING IN AND THEN GOING TO
HEAD OVER THIS WAY WE WILL
FOLLOW UP RIGHT NOW. WE ARE
WAITING WHILE WE DO THE
ABSENTEE CALLED ABSENTEES FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR MISSILE IN.
GREAT LITTLE IN RETURN. THANK
YOU ALL. IS THERE.
TEXTED.
OKAY
CENTER WELCOME. IF WE NEED TO
FILE ITEM SIX SB SIX SEVENTY
FIVE SENATORS WHEN YOU ARE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS TWENTY TO BE HERE
FIRST TIME BY THE WAY. SO SB
SIX SEVENTY FIVE WOULD SIMPLY
PROVIDE PARITY THAT COUNTY SAID
THE OPTION TO IMPLEMENT A
PROGRAM TO ALLOW TAXPAYERS FOR
SIXTY TWO YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER
OR WHO RECEIVE SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME TO PAY THEIR
PROPERTY TAXES. NO MONTHLY
INSTALLMENTS RATHER THAN TO
LUMP SUMS. THIS WOULD BE A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM. FOR BOTH OF
THE COUNTY AND THE TAXPAYER.
HAS EXISTING LAW STANDS NOW
PROPERTY TAXES ARE PAID INTO
ANNUAL INSTALLMENTS EXCEPT IF
AN OWNER IS IN DEFAULT. THE
SYSTEM BECOMES A PARTICULAR
PROBLEM WHEN HOMEOWNERS OWN
THEIR PROPERTY OUT RIGHT ARE NO
LONGER PAYING MONTHLY MORTGAGES
AND HAVE NO IMPOUND ACCOUNTS.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT
FOR TAXPAYERS RELIANCE FIXED
INCOMES SUCH AS THOSE OVER THE
AGE OF SIXTY TWO. AND TAXPAYERS
WHO RECEIVE SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME FOR DISABILITY.
SB SIX SEVENTY FIVE WILL ALLOW
COUNTIES TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
INDIVIDUALS LIVING ON FIXED
INCOMES. TO PAY THE PRINCIPLE
OF THE TAX DEADLY. THIS BILL IS
TIMELY GIVEN THE INCREASED
NUMBER OF OPTIONS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO COUNTY THANKS TO
RECENT TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES.
ONE SUCH OPTION IS A PROGRAM
DEVELOPED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
FINANCE COMMITTEE CALLED EASY
SMART PAY. IN COUNTIES THAT
OFFER THE EASY SMARTPAY
SOLUTION TAXPAYERS CAN CHOOSE
TO CREATE AN EASY SMARTPAY
ACCOUNT AND PAY PROPERTY TAXES
MONTHLY WITH A CREDIT. OR DEBIT
CARD. OR DIRECTLY FROM THE
CHECKING ACCOUNT THERE'S NO
COST TO THE COUNTY. NO COST TO
THE COUNTY. I KNOW NEED TO
DEVELOP A NEW SYSTEM FOR
SOFTWARE. AS EASY SMARTPAY CAN
INTEGRATE SEAMLESSLY WITH
EXISTING SYSTEMS. IS THE
SMARTPAY HAS BEEN IN THE PILOT
PHASE FOR THREE YEARS AT CSX
FINANCE COMMITTEE. AB SAY THEY
PLAN TO HAVE THIS PROGRAM
AVAILABLE TO ALL COUNTIES IN
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS. JOINING ME
ACTUALLY. TRACY ARE JOINING IN
TO TESTIFY SUPPORT IS ALLEGRA
FORTUNATE TO HAVE BEHALF THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
AND SCOTT KAUFMAN FROM THE DARK
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. THEIR CONTENT
THANK YOU WITH THE MODERATOR
CONNECT US WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE PLEASE.
HELLO. HI THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BURKE AND
MEMBERS I AM A LIQUOR FORTUNE
IDEA MEMBER FROM SAN FRANCISCO
OF THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE IN ORGANIZATIONS
SPONSORING THIS BILL WE WISH TO
EXPRESS OUR VERY STRONG SUPPORT
FOR S. B. SIX SEVENTY FIVE
WHICH ALLOWS COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE OPTION NOT
THREE ANOTHER REQUIREMENT OF
IMPLEMENTING A MONTHLY PROPERTY
TAX PAYMENT PROGRAM THIS BILL
IS MUCH NEEDED AND NECESSARY TO
BRING THIS ISSUE FORWARD IS IT
IS AN OPTION TO THE BI ANNUAL
PAYMENT SYSTEM THAT WILL HELP
HOME HOMEOWNERS MORE EASILY
MANAGE THEIR PAYMENTS NOT ONLY
FOR LOW INCOME IN OLDER ADULTS.
BUT FOR ADULTS WHO ARE CARING
FOR IN HANDLING FINANCES OF
THEIR OLDER FRAIL OR DISABLED
PARENTS SHE A MONTHLY PAYMENT
OPTION CAN ALSO TAKE A HUGE
BURDEN OFF CONSERVATIVES DO
SHAREEF AND OTHERS WHO SERVE
THIS POPULATION CREATING A
SYSTEM WITH AUTOMATIC
DEDUCTIONS HELPS THEM EASILY
MANAGE PROPERTY TAX PAYMENTS
THIS BILL ALSO FURTHERS THE
GOALS OF THE GOVERNOR'S. MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING. IT NEEDS TO BE
SAID THAT SB SIX SEVENTY FIVE
IS SILENT ABOUT THE METHOD OF
IMPLEMENTATION IT DOES NOT
DIRECT ANY COUNTY TO UPGRADE OR
REPLACE ANY EXISTING TAX
COLLECTION SYSTEM. AS AN
EXAMPLE OF AN INEXPENSIVE
ALTERNATIVE C. FACT FINANCE
CORPORATION AS CURRENTLY
DEVELOPED THE PAYMENT. GATEWAY
PLATFORM CALLED EASY SMART PAY
THAT ALLOWS HOMEOWNERS TO SET
UP AUTOMATIC MONTHLY PAYMENTS.
IT IS OPERATING WELL BEYOND ITS
PILOT PHASE IN NINETEEN IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE EASY SMART.
EASY SMART PAY DID NOT EXIST
WHEN A SIMILAR BILL PASSED BOTH
STATE LEGISLATIVE BODIES AND
WITH VETOED BY THE THEN
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN DUE TO
PROCEED BECAUSE- CURRENTLY THE
ONLY EXPENSE FOR COUNTIES IF
THE DOCTOR WOULD BE ADDING THIS
OPTION TO THEIR WEBSITE. AND
ADVERTISING IS AVAILABILITY TO
THEIR RESIDENTS I RESPECTFULLY
AND STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR S. B. SIX SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU THINK YOU WOULD THE
MODERATOR NOW CONNECT US WITH-
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. HELLO AND THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY-
DESPITE PROPOSITION THIRTEEN WE
CONTINUE TO GET CALLS EVERY
YEAR FROM RETIRED SENIORS ON
FIXED INCOMES ARE HAVING
TROUBLE PAYING THEIR PROPERTY
TAXES. THEY NEED ISRAEL AND
THAT IS WHY SB SIX SEVEN FIVE
IT'S SO IMPORTANT WELL THE
AMOUNT PAID WOULD ULTIMATELY BE
THE SAME PAIN IN SMALLER
MONTHLY INSTALLMENTS WOULD BE
MUCH MORE MANAGEABLE FOR THESE
HOMEOWNERS TEND TO LUMP SUMS.
FURTHER SB SIX M. FIVE IS NOT A
RADICAL IDEA OTHER STATES SUCH
AS IDAHO MICHIGAN OHIO AND
TEXAS FORTY OFFER MONTH MONTHLY
PROPERTY TAX PAYMENT PROGRAMS
AND IT SHOULD BE NOTED THIS
BILL DOES NOT IMPOSE A NEW
MANDATE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
COUNTY HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN
THAT THEY ARE TECHNOLOGICALLY
ON ABLE TO ESTABLISH A COMPUTER
SYSTEM TO ALLOW FOR MONTHLY
MONTHLY PROPERTY TAX PAYMENTS.
BUT EASY SMART PIG THIS AND SB
SIX SEVEN FIVE IT'S PERMISSIVE
IN MERELY GIVES COUNTY THE
OPTION TO DO THIS IF THEY SO
DESIRE I ASK YOU TO VOTE YES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE MAIN
LINE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
TESTIMONY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT TESTIMONY PLEASE PRESS
ONE NOW THAN THEIR- AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN PLEASE PRESS. ONE
NINE SEVEN ZERO. AND AT THIS
TIME THERE IS NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO SIT THAT TESTIFYING
SUPPORT THE REMOTE VIDEO ROOM.
SEEING NONE ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE.
MODERATOR I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
ONE PRIMARY WITNESS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY TREASURERS TREASURERS
AND TAX COLLECTORS PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AT THIS
IS KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY TREASURERS AND TAX
COLLECTORS IN OPPOSITION- ONCE
AGAIN TO THIS PROPOSED MEASURE-
I'VE HEARD DEFINITELY- THAT
PROPONENTS EXPLANATION BUT THIS
IS NOT A MANDATE. THAT YOU
SMARTPAY HAS ALREADY FIGURED
OUT HOW TO DO IT- THAT'S NICE
FOR E. S. P. BUT- THEY ACTUALLY
CHARGED THE PARTICIPANTS TWO
POINT FIVE PERCENT- ON EVERY
SINGLE TRANSACTION THAT'S NEED
CREDIT CARD OR- THROUGH THE A
CH THAT AUTOMATIC
CLEARINGHOUSE. SO THEY'RE
MAKING MONEY OFF OF PAIN
PEOPLES- GETTING PEOPLE TAXES
THE- BILLED MONTHLY THEY DO NOT
HAVE A CUSTOMER SUPPORT NUMBER.
AND AT THE END OF IT WHEN IT'S
TIME TO PAY THE TAXES TO THE
COUNTY THEY STILL PAID ON
DECEMBER TENTH AND APRIL TENTH
NOT BECAUSE COUNTY SYSTEMS WERE
DEVELOPED BASED ON EXISTING
STATUTE WHICH IS THAT THEY HAVE
TO COLLECT THEM BY DECEMBER TEN
AM APRIL TENTH. SO THEY MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS AND
WHAT THE STATUTE TOLD THEM THEY
NEEDED TO BE SET UP. AS AS FAR
AS MONTHLY BILLING WHICH WEEK
AND HAD A VERY LEAVES THE PHONE
CALL WITH THE SPONSOR AN
AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO GO THROUGH
THE CHALLENGES WITH.
IMPLEMENTING THIS BILL WE DO
NOT AS THE TAX COLLECTOR'S
OFFICE AND GET THE- WHAT NEEDS
TO BE PRINTED ON THE TAX BILL
UNTIL SOMETIME IN OCTOBER. OF
THE YEAR BY WHICH THE DECEMBER
TENTH PAYMENT NEEDS TO BE MADE
SO ULTIMATELY IN ORDER TO BILL
PEOPLE CORRECTLY THERE WOULD
ONLY BE POTENTIALLY TWO BILLION
CYCLES AT THAT. THIS WE WHEN WE
GET THAT THE BILL FROM THE
AUDITOR AND WHEN WE PRINT IT
AND MAIL IT OUT SO. I WOULD BE
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO HAVE A
MONTHLY BILLING SYSTEM THAT
WITH EVEN ACROSS ALL. TWELVE
MONTHS BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
ALL YOU GOES UP EVERY YEAR FOR
LUCKY AND- YOU KNOW VOTERS
APPROVED PARCEL TAXES AND SUCH
THAT RAISE THE COST OF THE TAX
BILL AND SO WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE ON THERE
UNTIL WE GET IT FROM THE OTHER.
AND THAT WOULD GIVE US ONLY TWO
MONTHS FOR THAT FIRST ONE EVEN.
IF YOU SMARTPAY HAS TO TRUE- AT.
AND WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO- IT
CHANGES THAT YEAR SO HAVE TO DO
THAT TO. I AS FAR AS DEMAND FOR
THE PRO- IN PHILOSOPHY SO
COUNTY WHICH IS A PARTICIPANT
IN EASY SMARTPAY. THEY HAVE
TWENTY SIX PEOPLE AND ROLLED.
SO GOING TO THE COST THE LOCAL
LEVEL. THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERN
YES THE TREASURY TAX COLLECTORS
AND IMPLEMENT SOMETHING LIKE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SPEND A LOT
OF MONEY. I INVESTING IN SOME
SORT OF OFFICE- OFFLINE
TRACKING SYSTEMS. THAT WOULD
THEN BE USED VERY VERY FEW
PEOPLE WHICH MEANS THAT THOSE
THAT ARE USING THAT ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO PAY LARGE FEES. TO
COVER THE COST OF THIS NEW
PROGRAM BECAUSE COUNTY TAX
COLLECTOR'S DON'T. CHARGE MONEY
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE THE BILL
WHAT THEY'RE TOLD TO BILL FOR
SO. THEY HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS
ABOUT IT THE- YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE COLLECTING IS. WHAT
FINDING. SCHOOLS SHERIFFS AND
POLICE DEPARTMENTS PUBLIC
HEALTH REGULAR HEALTHY. THERE'S
A LOT OF THINGS THAT REALLY
NEED TO BE DONE IGHT- AND SO
TRYING TO CREATE A NEW PROGRAM
WHICH LOOKS. LIKE A NICE THING
TO DO FOR SENIOR CITIZENS AND
FOLKS ON SOCIAL SECURITY. THIS
IS A LOT MORE COMPLICATED THAN
JUST- OPERATING. COUNTY TAX
COLLECTORS AND COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO DO THIS IN FACT
WE DON'T EVEN NEED LEGISLATION
IF THEY COULD DO WHAT THEY
WOULD DO IT. THERE'S JUST TOO
MUCH. COMPLICATION WITH IT AND
BASED ON THE FACT THAT THE
STATUTE SAYS DECEMBER TEN AND
YOUR FULL TIME SO. I RECOGNIZE
IT'S YOU KNOW A TOUGH ISSUE TO
SAY NO TO BUT WE'RE ASKING YOU
TO PLEASE ABSTAIN OR VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL. AND I NECESSARY TO
BEGIN WITH BUT SECONDLY IT
COULD HAVE VERY SIGNIFICANT
DOWN. DOWNSTREAM IMPLICATIONS
FOR COLLECTING TAXES THE WAY
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
COLLECTED TO FUND CRITICAL
PUBLIC SERVICE. AND CAROLINE I
CAN PRETTY MUCH I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE AND-
OPERATOR IF YOU WOULD OPEN THE
LINE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL.
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. AND
LADIES AND- IF YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
PLEASE PRESS. OUR WEBSITE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AND
WE DO HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE.
THIRTY FIVE. I BELIEVE ONE
THIRTY FIVE A LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO. I GUESS NINE THIRTY FIVE
IS NO LONGER THERE. IS THAT IT.
LET ME SEE LINE THIRTY FIVE ARE
YOU THERE YOUR BILL TO HEAR US.
YES I'M HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD LARA. SORRY
ABOUT THAT MIND AND- THIS IS
NOT LEVELING WITH THE STATUS
UPDATE THIS PATIENT COUNTY
AUDITORS- JUST BRIEFLY WANTED
TO TACKLE THE COMMENTS OF. MY
COLLEAGUE WITH THE TREASURER
TAX COLLECTOR'S WE'VE HAD A LOT
OF INTERNAL DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THIS ISSUE AND YOU KNOW AGAIN
NOT THE REPETITIVE THE WALLABY.
A GREAT SERVICE TO OFFER THEIR
SYSTEMS ARE TOO MANY QUESTIONS
AND COMPLICATIONS THAT NONE OF
US COULD. COME UP WITH WITH
VERY GO TO SOLUTIONS TO- YOUR
COUNTY BY COUNTY LET ALONE
STATEWIDE I THOUGHT THIS TIME
WE'D WE'D ASK YOU ENERGY TO
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE MODERATOR. AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NOBODY ELSE IN THE
QUEUE GREAT THANK YOU- ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION VIA REMOTE VIDEO.
SEEING NONE ANY OPPOSITION HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING
NINE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MR MAYES YOU
HAVE A QUESTION FOR- I GUESS
KAREN LANG YOU COULD PROBABLY
ANSWER THIS AS YOU READ THIS
BILL IT DOES THIS FORCE
COUNTIES TO DO THIS OR IS THIS.
OPTIONAL FOR COUNTIES TO DO
THIS. I ABSOLUTELY OPTIONAL
IT'S ONLY MEN THE CONCERN IS
THAT- THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WITH AUTHORITIES OF THE TAX
COLLECTOR WE NEED TO. IMPLEMENT
IT AND WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT-
THE ABILITY TO DO SO WITH OUR
EXISTING RESOURCES THAT IS
AGREED ABSOLUTELY AN OPTION NOT
REQUIRED. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I THINK- MANAGER I THINK
THIS IS A WONDERFUL BILL- IF
YOU'VE HEARD A CONSTITUENT AND
I'VE HEARD PROBABLY FIVE
CONSTITUENTS TELL ME. THAT
EVERY TIME THEY GET THAT BILL-
THESE ARE THESE ARE SENIOR
CITIZENS ON FIXED INCOMES.
USUALLY JUST SO SECURITY AND
THEY HAVE TO PAY THAT PROPERTY
TAX BILL. IT'S A BIG CHUNK OF
CHANGE AND THEY'VE GOT A TO GO
TO PUT OUT. AND SO- EVERYBODY
ELSE- HAS MONTHLY PAYMENTS
THERE'S NO REASON FOR US NOT TO
SET UP A SYSTEM THIS ISN'T
FORCING COUNTIES TO COMPLY THIS
IS AN OPTION FOR COUNTIES. WITH.
THAT THAT MIGHT BE SUPPORTIVE.
ANY OTHER AS A FROM THE- .ORG-
WELL I REALLY THINK THAT THIS
IS DECISION WE CAN LEAVE TO THE
pOPPORTUNITY- I'M SURE THAT THE
TAX COLLECTORS AND AUDITORS
SHOULD THEY DECIDE THIS IS
SOMETHING THEY'RE COUNTY
SHOULDN'T DO THEY CAN TALK TO
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ABOUT
IT SHOULD THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OKAY IT THERE'S
COSTS INVOLVED THEY'LL HAVE TO
FUND IT SO- JUST BECAUSE THIS
IS AN OPTION I'LL SUPPORT IT
FOR MANDATE I'D HAVE TO THINK
AGAIN. BUT I THINK WE CAN JUST
ALLOW THE COUNTIES TO DO WHAT'S
BEST FOR THEM AND THIS JUST
GIVES THEM AN OPTION SO ALL THE
SUPPORTING IT AS WELL. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE CENTER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
FOR YOUR COMMENTS APPRECIATE
THAT- I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY
THAT WE JUST GOT NOTICE THAT
THE EASY SMARTPAY- PILOT
PROGRAMS ACTUALLY BEEN. EXITED
AND NOW IT IS FULLY AVAILABLE
TO ALL COUNTIES IF THEY CHOOSE
TO USE IT IS THIS ON LET'S MOVE
IT OVER SORRY THERE YOU GO
THAT'S BETTER. DID YOU HEAR
ABOUT IT OKAY- AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE TO CLARIFY
THAT- I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
ON BEHALF OF THIS YEAR'S AYE
AYE I HOPE THAT THIS WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE- OUT
SUPPORTED BY THE COMMITTEE AND-
ONCE AGAIN IT IS AS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CORK MENTIONED AN OPTION
FOR BOTH THE COUNTIES AND OUR
SENIORS WHO BOTH OFTEN. BASED
ON WHAT WORKS BEST FOR THEM I
WITH THAT I LIKELY TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU AND TO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. GRADE WILL
BE SILENT CALL THE ROLL. BURKE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BURKE ALL
RIGHT WHEN. WHEN ARE YOU GREAT.
GREAT GRAYSON GRAYSON I LEVINE
LEVINE I'M MAYES MAYES AYE
MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE KIRK. I RIVAS
RIVAS I SAY ARE HIGH THERE'S A-
TEN ZERO THAT BILLS OUT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH JUST ONE SENATOR
ALAN. CAN WE CALL SENATOR
HERTZBERG. WELL IN THE- BOB
HERTZBERG WHITE- CILIC'S YOU-
MISSILE WE CALL THE ABSENTEES
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR. GREAT
HI GREAT I MULLIN SERTA HI
SARAH ON. THE WHOLE WORLD. WE
NEED TO FILE ITEM FOR SB SIX
ELEVEN SENATOR WHEN YOU ARE
READY SO I'M HERE YOUR
COLLEAGUES BIRTH A SIMILAR
STONE CALL ME JUSTICE- SENATE
JOB WAS WAS FINISHING UP OKAY.
SO THIS BILL AND SB SIX ELEVEN
BUILDS UPON THE FILM INDUSTRY'S
COMMITMENT TO TRAIN AND EMPLOY
MORE CALIFORNIANS FROM UNDER
PRESENT COMMUNITIES. SARAH SO
ANYWAY IT'S GOT A. THIRTY EIGHT
ZERO THIRTY THIRTY NINE ZERO
VOTE OVER THE SENATE HAPPY
DOESN'T QUESTIONS. EIGHT YOU
GET WE DON'T HAVE A WIN THIS
BECAUSE IT'S A HOLIDAY TODAY-
FOR MOST FOLKS THANK. COULD A
SIMPLE RESULT IN IT AND WE'RE
SO DISAPPOINTED- NO BITTERNESS
HERE AT ALL A MODERATOR WOULD
YOU NOW OPEN THE LINE MAINLINE
FOR SUPPORTING TESTIMONY PLEASE.
HELLO WHEN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS. ONE AT THAT VERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE NOT THAT THERE'LL.
AND MY NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THAT IN TURN MEMBERS
MADISON RALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF TALENT AGENTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. LINE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES THANK YOU ADD UP THE-
TEAMSTERS LOCAL THREE NINETY
NINE IN SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN IT WILL BE ADELINE
NUMBER THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CHANGE THEIR RECORD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABORS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
pOPEN. MY NUMBER TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MANY JOBS
WITH NIELSEN MARK MARK CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE DIRECTORS
GUILD OF AMERICA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LIE NUMBER THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. KATHY GARVEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA OUT TO
COUNSEL AND THE ENTERTAINMENT
UNION COALITION CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MATH
PROBLEM YEAH THE TEACHERS AND
BACK AFTER IN SUPPORT YEAH.
LINE NUMBER THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I BELIEVE A POINT
IS CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. AND THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU I IS THERE ANY OF
WITNESSES AND THE VIET VIDEO
FOR SUPPORT IN THAT REMOTE
VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NINE SUPPORT
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
WEST ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF CENTER
ALLEN'S BILL THANK YOU.
MODERATOR WE NOW OPEN THE LINE
FOR ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
PLEASE. HI MY ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAT THAN VERO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THAT THERE IS NO ONE THANK YOU
GRAY IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE REMOTE VIDEO
STATION. SEEING NINE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. A
THANK YOU SENATORS TO FIND
BILL- IN IN THE ANALYSIS AND
YOU KNOW SOME TRYING TO JUST
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT MORE
POWER GOING TO IMPACT PEOPLE
THERE'S A LOT OF PERCENTAGES
AND DOLLAR AMOUNTS DO WE HAVE A
SENSE OF THE UNIVERSE OF PEOPLE
THAT WILL BE IT YOU KNOW
POTENTIALLY CREATING MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AND- BOTH OF
THESE TYPES OF CAREER PATHWAY
PROGRAMS. IT'S A GOOD QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I YOU KNOW I
MEAN. IT'S A GOOD QUESTION I
DON'T LIKE TO ALONG WITH THIRTY
NINE VOTES IS TOUGH TO YOU KNOW
WORRY ABOUT THE DETAILS BUT
IT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT CAME
TO MY MIND OF YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
NOTICE WHO WHO ARE REALLY
IMPACTING AND- YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT WILL THIS- YOU ARE WE- ARE
WE SERVING IN. INCENTIVIZING
SERVING A POPULATION THAT
EXISTS. OUR WE ALSO- PERHAPS
IGNITING A LITTLE BIT OF FIRE
TO CREATE. MORE PROGRAMS THAT
REALLY COULD COULD SERVE THE
INDUSTRY WELL THAT'S EXACTLY
THE IDEA RIGHT THE IDEA IS
THAT- THAT. THAT BY GIVING A
LITTLE BIT OF INCENTIVE
ASSOCIATED WITH. WITH WITH THIS
SORT OF HIRING- IT WILL IT WILL
SPUR. SOME CHANGE WITHIN THE
INDUSTRY. AND AND HOPEFULLY
THINGS WILL THIS WILL START TO
BECOME THE NORM I'M I THINK ONE
OF THE MAJOR CONCERNS THAT A
LOT OF US HAVE IS THAT- THE
INDUSTRY'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF
A- YOU KNOW- BUT BUT PRETTY
CLOSE TO CLICK. FOR A LONG
TIME. AND IS IT JUST TRYING TO
OPEN UP A LITTLE BIT AND
HOPEFULLY IT'LL CHANGE. NORMS I
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE I'M ON MY OWN PART
I KNOW WE'RE NOT TAKING ANY
MOMENT HERE BUT WHEN THERE IS
THE OPPORTUNITY I LOVE THE OP I
WOULD LOVE THE OPTION TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. YEP WITH
THAT WILL COME OUT NO THANK YOU
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YEAH I THINK HE I
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT. AND
LOVE TO AT THE CHAIR AS A AS A
CO AUTHOR AND- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. IT IS HIGHLY WOULD
YOU CALL THE ROLL. BURKE HI
BURKE I WHEN GREAT. I GRAYSON
GRAYSON ALL RIGHT LEVINE I MEAN
I MAYES MAYES ISLAND
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK ALL RIGHT I
RIVAS RIVAS I SAY ARE TO.
NUMBER THEY'RE NOT VOTING.
SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU THAT BUILD
OUT SEVEN ZERO IF YOU COULD
SEND BACK SENATOR HERTZBERG
THAT BE GREAT. HE'S THE LAST.
ONE YEAH. THE TIME COMING- CALL
THE ABSENTEES ON FILE ITEM
SEVEN SB SEVEN NINETY TWO
PLEASE. GREAT. HELLO GRANO
MULLIN SARATOGA NO SIR DON'T
KNOW. THANK.
HE GOT. RIGHT
CENTER IS PRESENT AS WELL.
THAT.
WELCOME SENATOR WE NEED TO FILE
ITEM TO SB TWO SIXTY SEVEN
WE'RE SORRY TO PULL YOU AWAY
BUT THANK YOU. YOU ARE A LAST
OFFICE OKAY. SO THE- CITY
CALIFORNIA- HAS ADOPTED A
POLICY SOME YEARS AGO. THE
DEALT WITH INCENTIVIZING A
SOLAR DEVELOPMENTS IN EXEMPTING
THEM FROM. REAL ESTATE TAXES
PROPERTY TAXES THE PURPOSE OF
WHICH WAS TO. AGAIN TRY TO
PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF INCENTIVE
FOR. OUR GOVERNMENT TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE LARGER
POLICY ON RENEWABLES. THIS BILL
IS NECESSARY BECAUSE THERE'S A
PROBLEM IN THE PRACTICAL
APPLICATION OF FINANCING WITH
HOW THE LAW WORKS. IN FINANCING
JUST LIKE IN REAL ESTATE ANY
REAL ESTATE DEAL WHAT HAPPENS
IS THERE'S A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN A DEVELOPER WHO'S THE
PROMOTER AND THE INVESTOR SO
WHAT HAPPENS IS. THE WAY THESE
DEALS ARE STRUCTURED IS WE GIVE
A PREFERENCE TO THE INVESTOR TO
GET THEIR MONEY BACK FIRST SO
THEY KEEP TITLE TO THE PROPERTY
AND THEN HE GETS TRANSFERRED
OVER TO THE DEVELOPER ONCE THE
INVESTORS EARNED THEIR RATE OF
RETURN. WE SEE THIS IN ALL
TYPES OF DEALS TO WHAT ARE
CALLED TO IN TWENTY TERMS OF-
MERCHANT BANKS AND THE LIKE IT
AND SO THESE FINANCIAL
TRANSACTIONS. ON OUR THE WAY
BUSINESS WORKS AND THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION COMES ALONG CRAZY
CONFUSION WHICH IS LOOK CREATED
A LACK OF CONFIDENCE IN THE
MARKET PLACE I'VE INTRODUCED
THIS BILL TO CREATE CLARITY IN
TERMS OF HOW THIS FINANCING
STRUCTURE HAS WORKED. AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT INVESTORS HAVE
CONFIDENCE GOING FORWARD AS FOR
IPHONES. I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE
TO PROMISE TO GO WITNESSES YET.
PLEASE CONNECT AS WELL. I GOT
TO VOTE THIS IS RICK I'M OFF
FOR THE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION AND A LADY IN FRONT
OF THE GREATLY HUNTER. EDF
RENEWABLES THANK YOU MODERATOR.
THE LINE. I NEVER READ MY STUFF
I JUST TALK ABOUT MY A- DOCKING
JUMPING. THIS IS WHAT YOU WANT
THE LINE OPEN FOR HIS PRIMARY
WITNESSES THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION PLEASE.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WEEKEND THANK YOU. WALKING A
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- BUT IT IS WRITTEN OFF
AND I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION PASSED YEAH A- LOT
OF STRESS ARE STRONG SUPPORTER.
TO SIXTY SEVEN FIFTY TO SIXTY
SEVEN OBVIOUSLY IT IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR SB TWO SIXTY SEVEN. HOW
WE ARE THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
FOR THE STRAW INDUSTRY I
REPRESENTING- SOLAR COMPANIES
ACROSS THE WHOLE VALUE CHAIN
MEMBERS ARE INVEST ABOUT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY- SB TWO FIFTY SEVEN SEVEN
SIMPLY CLARIFIES- THE STATUE
PROBABILITY OF THE INTERACTION
BETWEEN THE CURRENT PROPERTY
TAX EXCLUSION AND A COMMENT
SOLAR FINANCING STRUCTURE CALL
THE PARTNERSHIP SLEPT. UNDER
THE PARTNERSHIP WITH- AND THESE
ARE USED TO FINANCE- BUT MOST
SORE ENERGY SYSTEMS BUILT IN
CALIFORNIA AND THESE ARE USED
AS A WAY TO MAXIMIZE THE
FEDERAL BACK ABOUT THE TAX
CREDIT NEITHER KEY TAX MEASURES
THAT YOU HELPED DRIVE DOWN THE
COST OF SOLAR- AND- THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH IS JUST A
STRUCTURED YOU USED IT TO
REALLY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT
FEDERAL INVESTMENT TAX CREDIT.
FOR CALIFORNIANS- AND THAT HAS
REALLY HELPED MAKES ALONG ONE
OF THE CHEAPEST SOURCE OF
ENERGY ON ON CONNOR SO ACTUALLY
TWO SIXTY SEVEN PROVIDE THE
SIMPLE STOP STORY
CLARIFICATION- THAT PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL CERTAINTEED SOLAR
INVESTMENTS IN INSURANCE
CALIFORNIA CAN REMAIN VOCAL
LEADER NOT ABOUT MANY OF AN
INSTALLATION OF SOLAR ENERGY.
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND
URGING HI FOLKS ON THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE-
MODERATOR WE YOU CONNECT US.
WITH EDF RENEWABLES PLEASE.
YEAH DOING ANY HUNTER. GOOD
ACTORS MADAM CHAIR NUMBER
TELLING ON THE OF BOTH ET
RENEWABLE AND EDP RENEWABLE
LIKE RICK THE PART WITH CAN
IMPORT TOOL FOR SILICON VALLEY
CALIFORNIA- AT SENATOR
HERTZBERG STATED BACK IN TWENTY
ELEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER HELD
PASSED AB FIFTEEN ACTS-
CONFIRMING- THIS LEGISLATORS
INTENT RELATIVE TO THE USE OF
THE PARTNERSHIP CLIP BUT WHEN
THE BE A WE- PRODUCT GUIDANCE.
IT LEFT A COUPLE OF THINGS A
LITTLE UNCLEAR. SB TWO SIXTY
SEVEN PROVIDE THAT CLARITY-
WHICH IS MUCH NEEDED TO
CONTINUE TO ALLOW FOR FULLER
INVESTED TO CONTINUE TO HAPPEN
CALIFORNIA- WE THINK THAT TO
SIXTY SEVEN AND A- SIMPLE BILL
THAT DOES PROVIDE THAT CLARITY
AND I TAKE SOME OF THE RISK OUT
OF SOLAR INVESTMENT WHICH CAN
HELP. LEAD CALIFORNIA TO
ACHIEVE ITS ULTIMATE CLIMATE
AND CLEAN ENERGY GOALS FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SIXTY SEVEN
TODAY THANK YOU MODERATOR WE
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TESTIMONY.
AND AGAIN ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT HELPLINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THAT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
LINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AFTERNOON THIS IS LEAH
BARRACK ON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS
APPROPRIATION IN COURT. FINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AT. GOOD AFTERNOON CONTRACTING
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN CLEAN
POWER CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. AND
I'LL BE JUST A MOMENT WE HAVE
ONE MARK YOU. AND LINE NUMBER
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE.
I'M SORRY I'M CATHERINE HOKEY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. AND THAT THIS TIME
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IN THE
REMOTE VIDEO STATION AT THIS
TIME. SEEING NONE ANYONE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING
NINE I UNDERSTAND THERE'S ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS- IN OPPOSITION
WITH THE MODERATOR PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH THE COUNTY OF
KERN. HERE THIS IS LORALAI
OBIANO REPRESENTING THE KERN
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE KERN COUNTY
PLANNING A NATIONAL RESEARCH
DEPARTMENT WHICH FIRST WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THE AMENDMENTS THAT LIMITED
THIS TO ONE PARTNERSHIP LEAD
BUT WE ARE STILL CLOSE TO BEST
SPELL. BECAUSE IT ESSENTIALLY
CHANGES THE AGREEMENTS. THAT
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THOUGHT WE HAD. WHEN WE
APPROVED. FORTY THOUSAND ACRES
OF SOLAR. HE THIRTY THOUSAND
ACRES OF SOLAR PAYS ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR AND
COUNTY GENERAL FUND
CONTRIBUTIONS BUT WILL PAY
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS. WE ARE
CERTAINLY THE PATHWAY 21100%
RENEWABLE FOR CALIFORNIA. I
REVIEWED ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE ARE GREEN
ELECTRONS ARE BOUGHT BY A
VARIETY OF- UTILITIES AND POWER
YOUR DISTRICTS. AND YET KERN
COUNTY CANNOT GET THE PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE THAT A NORMAL
PROJECT WOULD PROVIDE. WE ARE
ONLY ASKING FOR EQUITY. IF. IF
THERE'S IF THIS AMENDMENT IS
MERELY A CLARIFICATION THEN THE
ASSESSOR'S ASSOCIATION WOULD
AGREE WITH THAT AND THEY DO NOT
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM MY LETTER
HE THEREFORE WOULD LIKE TO ASK.
THE SENATOR. AMEND THIS BILL
FOR A LIMITED TAXATION
REQUIREMENTS ON THE ONE
PARTNERSHIP LET. ME ASK YOU
COMMITTEE CHU NOT APPROVE THIS
BILL WE ARE NOT ASKING FOR A
FULL ASSESSMENT. OF ALL COST
UNDER THIRTY SUPPORT BUT THE
AMOUNT THAT WOULD NORMALLY GO
TO THE COUNTY. WE NOT ONLY HAVE
FORTY THOUSAND ACRES ALREADY
APPROVED YET ANOTHER TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND ACRES IN
PROCESS. FOR CONSIDERATION AND
INCLUDE SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS OF BATTERY STORAGE WE
PROVIDE OVER 50% OF THE
RENEWABLE ENERGY FOR
CALIFORNIA. IF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CHAVEZ STREET
WANTED TO GIVE UP EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TAX REVENUE
WILL BATTLEFIELD WE NEED TO
HAVE FAIR AND EQUITABLE
TAXATION OF THE SOLAR INDUSTRY
AND I KNOW THE WORD OF THE WORD
CHEAP GREEN ELECTRONS. I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THEY ARE
CHEAP BECAUSE KERN COUNTY DOES
NOT GET ITS PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE. SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
US TO- PROVIDE YOU THIS
INFORMATION AND ONCE AGAIN LIKE
TO THANK THE DOCTOR STARTED HER
SUPPORT FOR THE AMENDMENT
LIMITING TWO ONE PARTNERSHIP
BUT- THANK YOU WE ARE COULD YOU
POST THE BILL AS PREVENTATIVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AT
MODERATOR IS OR ANYONE ELSE ON
THE LINE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE LINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ROB GROWS CLOSER
MAP THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION NOT TO THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THE MOST
RECENT AMENDMENT AND WITH THAT
AMENDMENT WE HAVE REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
MODERATOR. THIS TIME IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE NOW AND THEN ZERO.
AND THERE IS NO ONE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
REMOTE VIDEO STATION AT THIS
TIME. SEEING NINE ANY
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE. OF COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEN SEEN NONE
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I WOULD I'D LIKE TO. ADDRESS
THE ISSUE FROM KERN COUNTY
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
AS IT RELATES TO PUBLIC POLICY.
FIRST OF ALL KERN COUNTY WOULD
NOT HAVE HAD THAT THE- NUMBER
OF- SOLAR PANELS IN THE AMOUNT
OF. EXPOSURE DOES IF THIS TAX
STRUCTURE OF JUST FINANCING
INVESTMENT STRUCTURE WAS
PERCEIVED THE WAY THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT NOW SECONDLY THE
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
THEY'RE TALKING AS MEGAWATTS
WHATEVER THE NUMBERS WERE. THE
THAT THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
WOULD NOT HAPPEN BECAUSE
INVESTORS WOULD NOT INVEST THE
WAY THE FLIP WORKS AND THE WAY
THE RISK PROFILE WORKS IN THESE
SITUATIONS IS THAT INVESTORS
INVEST THEY WANT THEIR MONEY
BACK FIRST. THIS WAS A
CHALLENGE BECAUSE BY BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION RECENT
INTERPRETATION THAT WAS NEVER
IT THEY ARE RAISING A LARGER
ISSUE. ABOUT HOW WE AS A
GOVERNMENT CHOOSE TO SUBSIDIZE-
SOLAR ENERGY AND TO TRY TO
INCENTIVIZE SOLAR EDGE I GET
THAT AND I'M TOLD THAT THEY
PROVIDES PUT JUST 53% FROM THAT
COUNTY LEGITIMATE ISSUE. BUT
IT'S NOT RELATED TO THIS
MEASURE IT'S A SEPARATE ISSUE
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING
HERE IS A LITTLE LEVERAGE JOB A
LITTLE BIT BUT IT'S OKAY YOU
KNOW IT'S WORTH THE DISCUSSION
WE'VE LIMITED TO ONE FLIP ONLY
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL THE PURPOSE
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO. KEEP
FLIPPING THESE THINGS ARE JUST
TRYING TO LEGITIMIZE THE
UNDERLYING FINANCIAL
TRANSACTIONS SO. I JUST WANT TO
SHARE THAT WITH YOU BECAUSE IT
I UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION
OUT AND IN A NUMBER OF FOLKS OF
TALK TO ME ABOUT IT AND I GET
IT. AND AS YOU KNOW WE DEVELOP
PUBLIC POLICY IN THIS PLACE
OFTEN THINGS CHANGE I REMEMBER
WHEN THE INTERNET WASN'T TAXED
AND THEN IT STARTED TO BECOME
TAXED RIGHT BECAUSE THE CHANGE
CHANGE AND THESE WILL CHANGE
OVER TIME. AS WE MATURE AND
DEVELOP THESE PROCESSES BUT
WORD THAT INFLECTION POINT
WHICH IS CAUSING THE
FRUSTRATION SECOND THING I WANT
TO TAKE EXCEPTION TO. IS MY
EXTRAORDINARY- SPONSOR ON THE
STILL ANY HUNDRED CALL THIS A
SIMPLE BILL I'VE NEVER
INTRODUCED A SIMPLE BILL IN MY
LIFE I. SPOKE I JUST WANT TO
PUT THAT ON RECORD THAT WE
DON'T DO CIVIL BILLS BUT THAT
EVENT WITH THAT I DESPERATE AYE
VOTE THANK YOU FOR THAT SENATOR
WE HAVE A MOTION. AND A SECOND
TIME WHEN YOU CALL THE ROLL.
BURKE I WE'RE ALL RIGHT WHEN.
GREAT HI GREAT I. GRAYSON AYE
LEVINE. I MEAN I MAYES HI MAYES
I'M ALL IN. PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I LIKE WORK ON
GROUP I RIVAS RIVAS I SAY ART
OF MINE CLEARED A LOT. NINE
ZERO NINE BILLS OUT NINE ZERO
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM THREE I WOULD
BE FIVE THIRTY NINE. THANK
THANK YOU I'LL MAKE IT BRIEF
LAST YEAR- THE NUMBER OF
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE. CHAIR BURKE.
ASSEMBLY BOWMAN FRIEDMAN GREAT
SOME IMMIGRATION CENTER MAYES
INTRODUCED ACA ELEVEN AFTER A
SERIES OF DISCUSSIONS OF THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. AND AC
ELEVEN WAS A PRETTY ELEGANT
COMPROMISE THAT ALLOWED FOR
PORTABILITY. OF PROPERTY TAXES
OF SOMEBODY SAY WAS IN L. A.
COUNTY HAVE THE HOUSE THEY
BOUGHT FOR THIRTY THOUSAND IS
OUR TWO MILLION THEY COULD MOVE
TO EL DORADO COUNTY SOME OTHER
PART OF THE STATE ALLOWED FOR
PORTABILITY FOR SENIORS TO BE
ABLE TO DO SUCH IT ALSO CREATED
THE BENEFIT. OF UNLOCKING THAT
TAX REVENUE FOR THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION WITHIN SAN
FRANCISCO OR SAN DIEGO ORANGE
COUNTY WAS PRETTY ELEGANT WHAT
ARE THE CHALLENGES IN TRYING TO
CREATE PORTABILITY WITH THE
REALTORS. WAS THAT IN THE
COUNTIES THAT PEOPLE MOVE TO
WHERE THE WHERE THAT THE AMOUNT
OF PROPERTY TAX PAID WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE OLD NUMBER IT BECAUSE
CHALLENGES FOR THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE FIRE
DISTRICTS SO WE CREATED YOU
CREATED PART OF ALL OF US IN
THIS LEGISLATURE ON TWO THIRDS
BILL. AC ELEVEN WITH THE LEAD
AUTHORS I JUST ARTICULATED AND
IT PASSED BY VOTERS AS
PROPOSITION NINETEEN. THAT
WOULD ALWAYS HAPPENS IN THESE
SITUATIONS IS THAT WOULD
PROPERTIES CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT BY THE WAY. SO SOME
PEOPLE ARE BELLY ACHING ABOUT
THE CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
AND IF THEY WANT TO CHANGE IT
THEN GO BACK TO THE BALLOT
CHANGES THE CHALLENGE HERE IS
THE REQUIRED SOME
CLARIFICATIONS AND- WHETHER
IT'S INCONSISTENCIES WHICH HAVE
TAKEN THE FOLKS IN THE ASSESSOR
WORLD AND- THOSE FOLKS ARE.
FREDDIE COULD SAID THAT THERE'S
MY CHIEF OF STAFF HUNDREDS OF
HOURS OF TIME IN MEETING AFTER
MEETING. DEFINING A FAMILY
FARM. DEALING WITH THE KINDS OF
ISSUES THAT WE NEED THE CLARITY
FOR. AND DEALING WITH THE
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGE THAT
THE TREASURES DIDN'T LIKE THAT
WE WERE GOING TO PUT THE
REQUIREMENT OF PUTTING THE WEB
ADDRESS ON THE FRONT OF AN
ENVELOPE AND WE HAVE. TAKEN
THAT AMENDMENT TO REMOVE THAT.
SO THE MEMBERS THAT WE'VE TAKEN
WHICH WE AGREE TO. OUR CLARITY
AMENDMENTS CONSISTENCY
AMENDMENTS. THE N. OPERABILITY
AMENDMENTS AND CRAP AND QUITE
FRANKLY AMENDMENTS THAT GIVE
CERTAIN EMERGENCY POWERS TO THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION. TO HELP
WITHIN THE FRAME CONSTITUTIONAL
FRAMEWORK. TO IMPLEMENT THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL MOMENT THAT YOU
ALL PUT ON THE BALLOT. THAT
ASKS FOR NO VOTE WE HAVE.
CHRISTY BAMA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. AND VANESSA
TRAVIS WITH THE IT CALIFORNIA'S
OCEAN OF REALTORS. AS STAR
WITNESSES. IN THIS ENDEAVOR
THANK YOU MODERATOR WE PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHRISTY BELLA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF MEASURE AND- HERTZBERG
ALWAYS ELOQUENTLY. IDENTIFIED
THE COMPROMISED IN THE CONTEXT
OF THIS BILL SO I JUST WILL AB
JUST EXPRESS MY THANKS. TO THE
COMMITMENT OF DEDICATED FUNDING
THAT WILL START ACCRUING IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE FIRE
DISTRICTS- WHICH MAKES THESE
CONFORMING CHANGES. CRITICAL
AND THIS THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WHO LET US. IN THIS
EFFORT TO SUPPORT. WORLD BY
DISTRICTS. AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU WITH
THE MODERATOR CONNECT US WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE NASA
CHáVEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND WE
ARE VERY PLEASED TO JOIN
SENATOR HERTZBERG IN TWO. EIGHT
FIVE THIRTY NINE FIRST I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN BY GIVING SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR HIS AMAZING
LEADERSHIP AND BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE FORWARD I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
AND THANK THE CO AUTHORS. THEIR
STAFF AND COMMITTEE STAFF AND A
TIRELESS WORK ON THIS MEASURE
LAST YEAR WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT C. A. R. ALONG WITH THE
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
EFFECTIVELY COOK FONG EPA
ELEVEN WHICH A LOT OF THOSE WHO
ARE AGE FIFTY FIVE OR OLDER
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES AND
VICTIMS OF WILDFIRES OR NATURAL
DISASTERS GREATER FREEDOM TO
TRANSFER IT THEIR PROPERTY TAX
REBATES. THIRTY FIVE THIRTY
NINE IF THE CRITICAL
COMMONSENSE MEASURE THAT OUT
WILL AFFECT WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROPOSITION
NINETEEN. WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR EYEBALL ON SB FIVE
THIRTY NINE AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH.
STAKEHOLDERS ALONG THE WAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH
MODERATOR NOW THE MAIN LINE FOR
ANY INTO IN THE AND. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE OF
THEM ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
AND AT THE TIME THERE IS NO ONE
IN Q. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE VIDEO REMOTE STATION IN
SUPPORT. BEING NINE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NINE
MODERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINE FOR ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY PLEASE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THIS PRESS ONE THEN ZERO OR IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION. FIND
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR MIND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A LITTLE BACKED UP BY
THE MODERATOR MY APOLOGIES THE
CROP GROWTH BECAUSE OF NAFTA
CALIFORNIA TESTERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU OKAY. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
MODERATOR. AND AT THIS TIME IF
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND
THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
AND ME IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
IN THE REMOTE VIDEO ROOM SEEING
NONE ANY OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE DR CORK. YES NO
HARPER HOWARD JARVIS
ASSOCIATION ASKED FOR
CLARIFICATION IN WORDING- EARLY
ON. IS THAT RING A BELL NO OUR
WELL. I'M STILL. THEY DID I
SUSPECT YOU'VE YOU'VE IN- WHAT
WAS THE CORRECT SERVICES- THEIR
NATURE THEY'RE NEW TO NOW SO
LEARNED NOW FOR YES YOU MUST
HAVE CORRECT IT WAS NAMED
GUILTY SENT VITAMINS NOT DRUG
WITH TO SPEAK LATIN. I DON'T
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. CLARIFIED
IT WHATEVER IT IS THIS FOR A
LOT OF PLEDGES DON'T KNOW THIS
ON THE NEEDS TO CRACK HIS WORK
JUST NEED TO CLARIFY IT FOR
HARD JARVIS I HAVE NO DOUBT IT
ONLY WERE. TO ACTIVELY YOU VERY
MUCH YOU SHOULD- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE. COENEN I DO. NOT
CENTER I WON AT THE YOU IS THIS
EIGHT. ATTACK A VERY TASK AT
THAT- ACA ELEVEN I THINK YOU
WERE OVERLY GENEROUS WAS NOT I
DON'T THINK BRITAIN AS WELL AS
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN AND AS A
RESULT THE PROPOSITION IS NOT
AS CLEAR OR AS WELL WRITTEN AS
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN. I AM VERY
PROUD OF PORTIONS OF THAT
PROPOSITION THEIR OTHER
PORTIONS THAT I THINK IN
HINDSIGHT I MIGHT HAVE. LEFT
OUT. THAT BEING SAID THE WORK
THAT YOU HAVE DONE ON THIS TOOK
A LONG TIME TOOK A LOT OF WORK
AND I WANT TO PERSONALLY THANK
YOU FOR THAT THANK. YOU I KNOW
HOW HARD IT WAS SO WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THIS
ONE ALSO THANGKA. SIMILAR
MULLIN WHO JUST JOINED WHO IS
THE- ALSO ONE OF THE FIVE- LEAD
AUTHORS ON THIS AND TO.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU SENATOR JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION I UNDERSTAND THAT
IN ADDITION TO ACCEPTING THE
MEMONS NOTED IN THE COMMENT SEE
ON THE CAMINO SAYS YOU ALSO
AGREE TO ACCEPT THE MOMENTS TO
DELETE THE END OF A BLOKE
NOTICE PROVISION OF THE BILL
AND REVISED THE DEFINITION OF
FULL CASH VALUE OF THE ORIGINAL
PROPERTY FOR WILD FIRES. AND
DISASTERS IS THAT CORRECT THANK
YOU. GREAT WITH THAT. I WOULD
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE WIN. GREAT THREE I GRAYSON
GRAYSON I LIVING I MEAN I MAYES.
MAYES I'M MULLIN LOWLAND I
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
LIKE WORK. I RIVAS RIVAS ICE
THEY ARE TO NOT BELIEVE THERE
ARE ENOUGH VOTING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NINE ZERO THAT IS OUT NINE
ZERO. FLEA'S HIGHLAND I BELIEVE
WE HAVE SOME ABSENTEES TO GOING
THROUGH FILE ITEM TO SB TWO
SIXTY SEVEN I NEED TO MAKE SURE
MISS I MISS SEEING THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS ONLINE. I'LL FILE
ITEM TO SB TWO SIXTY SEVEN
WE'LL CALL THE ABSENTEES PLEASE.
WHEN MULLIN HI MULLIN I. FILE
ITEM THREE SB FIVE THIRTY NINE
WHEN. OKAY. SIX ELEVEN FILE
ITEM FOR SB SIX ELEVEN CALL THE
ABSENTEES WHEN MULLIN HI.
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I.
FILE ITEM FIVE SB SIX SIXTY
SEVEN CENTS OUT OF CONSENT
THERE WE GO FILE ITEM SIX SB.
SIX SEVENTY FIVE COMMITTEE
ABSENTEES MULLIN. MULLIN I.
SEVEN NINETY TWO FILE ITEM
SEVEN SB SEVEN NINETY TWO
MULLIN. FIVE ONE NINE. AND I
NEED TO GET MISTER MULLIN ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND THEY
CAN THANK CALENDAR MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE. WITH THAT. SHE JUST
MISSED WHEN.
SORRY. FILE ITEM-
SORRY. CAN WE CALL THE
ABSENTEES ON FILE ITEM THREE SB.
FIVE THIRTY NINE. WHEN I WHEN I.
I CALL THE ABSENTEES ON FILE
ITEM FOR SB SIX ELEVEN. WHEN
NOT BUILDING WHEN NOT VOTING
FILE ITEM FIVE SB SIX AT SIX
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENTEES. THAT'S ON CONSENT.
SIX SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX OH
SORRY- FILE ITEM TO AS B. TWO
SIX SEVEN WHEN I WHEN I. SORRY
EFFORTS. WITH THAT. WE ARE
EJECT.